l'allemagne fédérale fera demain son
ambassade à budapest elle pourrait
bientôt fermer son ambassade à prague
comme elle l'a déjà fait pour sa
représentation diplomatique à berlin est
un problème politique diplomatique
c'est un problème très concret pour
beaucoup d'allemands de l'est en effet
les ambassades fédérales allemandes sont
envahis actuellement par des réfugiés
d'allemagne de l'est qui veulent tout
simplement partir pour l'ouest en
principe comme totalement s'étaient
réfugiés au droit à un passeport de la
république fédérale simplement la
hongrie la tchécoslovaquie l'allemagne
de l'est sont très solidaires pour
empêcher tous ces gens de quitter leur
sol ce problème rappelle aujourd'hui 28
ans après la construction du mur de
berlin que ce mur coupe toujours le
rapport 2 c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
philippe couderc cette manifestation est
devenue un classique du genre
il y a tout d'abord l'hommage rendu aux
victimes du stalinisme c'est à dire tout
ce qu'ils ont trouvé la mort en tentant
de passer de l'est à l'ouest
ensuite on se rend à checkpoint charlie
point de passage obligatoire entre les
deux zones pour réclamer la destruction
du mur érigé
il y à 28 ans aujourd'hui wolfgang
hautes-alpes hull né à l'est célébrer le
23e anniversaire de son passage à
l'ouest
il s'est allongé de part et d'autre de
la ligne de démarcation sous l'oeil des
manifestants mais aussi sous les regards
des vopos qui ont immédiatement demandé
à leurs collègues occidentaux de faire
circuler pour éviter tout incident
depuis une quinzaine de jours on
constate en effet un regain de tension
entre les deux allemagnes nombreux sont
les allemands de l'est qui profitent de
leurs vacances pour passer à l'ouest via
les représentations diplomatiques
d'allemagne fédérale en particulier
celle de berlin est et celle de budapest
l'affluence est telle qu'à berlin une
dizaine de candidats à l'évasion font
retourner chez eux pour passer la nuit
il se représenteront dans quelques jours
assuré de ne pas être inquiété à
budapest même situation
l'ambassade d'allemagne fédérale sera
fermée à partir de demain
400 allemands de l'est qui attendent
leurs visas raison de cet exode massif
la non évolution du régime de pankow le
fait de se sentir quelque peu étranger
chez soi alors qu'à l'ouest seront vite
et l'on respire me
et puis comment admettre qu'elle murs
séparent encore les deux allemagnes
alors que le rideau de fer n'existe plus
entre la hongrie et l'autriche
ici l'on peut tenter sa chance par les
chemins de traverse avec ou sans visa